now you can see I've got one two three
four values and I need to know which one
is highest and which one is lowest so
I'm going to do a table about there's no
way to get away from this you have to
test all these points okay so therefore
I have one two three four coordinates
the table I'll show you so I've got five
columns because I am NOT testing eggs
against the first derivative or X
against the second derivative I actually
want to know where is the function how
high or low am i what's the matter
little even though okay now I look at my
numbers a half five one three and I'm
just going to put them in order
right 1/2 comes first it's the leftmost
endpoint one and three are in the middle
and five is on the end okay not that you
have to do this but these four points
I'm testing they're not all the same
you've got n points here and here
beeping four endpoint well you could say
B you'll sometimes see B be a boundary
value and in the middle here I've got
two stationary points now all I need to
do is just I need to plug in the values
that's all that's required here okay so
for instance I'm not going to do the
endpoints just yet I'm going to do these
two in here right now it doesn't take
too much to see you can get zero and
okay that's the young that's the
intercept there and you can work that
out that's just number crunching okay
and do you see why I do bother to
determine the nature of these stationary
points like I don't need to this is the
local mister the relative maximum and
this is the relative minimum but it's
it's lower of course it's the relative
minimum how could it be the relative
Matt is lower than the other stationary
so I didn't need to make any fancy
arguments about that there I've got the
stationary point values but I also need
to see well what happens here in here
okay now I've crutch these numbers
already for you you can
reiji's if you like and get some numbers
but you should get these now the really
interesting thing happens when you look
at this now I've got all the possible
places where I could be highest or
lowest right what's the lowest you can
see it's negative all right there's the
minimum the actual minimum which happens
to correspond with the stationary point
so this relative minimum is also the
absolute minimum okay I'll write that
all at the center where's the max it's
the maximum itself is 16 and it occurs
at x equals 5 it's this guy right
so my relative maximum here is not the
absolute maximum the endpoints okay now
really quickly on the basis of this just
really roughly sketch this okay it's not
hard to draw
okay now we are we're answering two
different kinds of problems here okay
if all I'm interested in is tell me
where the highest is tell me where the
lowest then I don't need to be fine and
rigorous in determining what kind of
stationary point of view for example I
don't care whether it's a horizontal
point inflection or not that has no
relevance to this the actual question
I'm trying to answer because it's a
maximum interval of time and once I
determine the nature like I still need
to know what the actual value is anyway
to know about how it compares to the end
points right so that's life all right
let's just really quickly join us so
here is my domain
okay so I'm just going to plot these
points right at 1/2 I'm gonna get from
1/2 to fine so if I say one two three
four five there's one end point that
means a half is about there okay so and
a half I'm at negative seven point eight
actually this is going to tell with my
staring something like that let's call
that minus seven over eight at one which
is right there this is a stationary
point right so I'm not only going to put
a point there I'm going to put the
horizontal line there as well to
indicate what's happening at three one
two three I'm at negative four so that's
like down here somewhere right down here
so I'm gonna put that there I'm also
gonna put a horizontal line through it
to indicate it would be a stationary
point in a second and then at five I'm
all the way up at 16 there's my end
point okay so I have four dots and all I
have to do is join the dots right you
wanna raise efficient okay okay
look at where I'm gonna go stationary
point stationary point and I've got a
picture there do you see how like what
other kind of pop could i trace given
this is where the stationary points are
it's the many endpoints are I'm done and
now you can see obviously why this is
the
this event absolutely minimal right this
input over here doesn't get low enough
where I to extend the domain further
over here it's a cubic right it's going
to drop off like this but in the
particular domain I'm interested in this
is the one and of course up here here's
my absolute max so I did say this
verbally before but I'll just on writer
as well how am I going to conclude this
I would say the absolute minimum the
minimum itself is this value minus 4
that's the lowest it can actually go the
absolute minimum is minus 4 which
happens at x equals 3 and likewise the
absolute maximum
is this actual value 16 which occurs at
x equals 5 correct that's right I'm
looking for that the function itself
that's true
and now as well we know your picture you
can see the folly of ignoring influence
why do I have to test the in words in
all you got is the stationary points
right you're kind of ignoring lots of
significant parts of the function I can
go way higher that's the real absolute
matter not a relative